et cette affaire provoque des divisions
au sein même de la majorité si
l'opposition elle se retrouve unie pour
appeler jackes Chirac à la négociation
l'initiative de Gill deobien à droite ne
fait pas l'unanimité y compris dans son
propre parti Roland Sicard et Philippe
DeLand les S papiers ne voulaiit pas
manquer leur rendez-vous un entretien
dans un palais officiel il le souhaitait
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs l'impatience
était telle qu'ils étaient un peu en
avance d'accord donc on va attendre
devant la porte il faut dire que si à
gauche tout le monde est d'accord pour
réclamé une négociation dans la majorité
Gilles deobien est l'un des premiers à
faire un geste résultat une heure et
quart d'entretien et à la sortie le
constat d'une situation difficile j'ai
le sentiment aujourd'hui que ils sont
demandeurs de
dialogue qu'il comprennent la complexité
de la situation au regard de la loi
française
qu'il perçoivent bien que la situation
de tous dans
l'église n'est pas
identique et que des solutions modulées
et au cas par cas sont sont à rechercher
seulement Gilles deobien paraît isolé à
l'UDF certains le critique quant au RPR
et au gouvernement ils font bloc autour
de Jean-Louis Debray Jean-Louis Debray
il a le devoir impérieux de faire ce que
l'on attendu c'est-à-dire son travail de
ministre donc je le soutiens tout à fait
et je crois qu'il ne faut pas se laisser
déborder par ceux qui en mal de cause
ont décidé du utiliser ces pauvres sans
papier comme une chair à canon politique
il y a eu une majorité de députés et de
sénateurs qui ont voté des lois ces lois
s'appliquent le gouvernement ne peut pas
transgresser à cela ou alors il n'est
plus digne de sodam en tout cas la
réception des S papiers à l'Assemblée
montre bien que l'affaire se déplace sur
le terrain politique entre une gauche
qui mobilise et une majorité qui se
divise le gouvernement doit trouver une
solution et est rentré en fin
d'après-midi à Paris un peu plus tôt que
prévu